I don't dance I feel like music just
makes you feel like you should dance but
I don't ever want to get right to the
conversation so just a few introductory
remarks I said at the beginning today I
think we all realized in the university
world the United States at least but
especially at Columbia that the world
has changed dramatically in the past
five years certainly ten years the
forces at work are reshaping our world
and we as academics as teachers and
researchers must find our way into this
new world to figure out what are the
issues that need our attention as
researchers and as teachers so this
panel today is to try to explore the
phenomena of globalization and we'll try
to link it back to Columbia you should
know already Colombia is probably the
most international the most global
university in the United States in many
respects at least has the second largest
absolute number of international
students of any institution in the
country very proud about that and hope
to expand it we have of course the
school of international public affairs
which is our core sort of discipline and
school devoted to this but we also have
the Earth Institute we have the
Committee on global thought we have
teachers college and all it does mailman
School of Public Health Medical School
the law school has a number of programs
Chinese legal studies the business
school and and the like one of the
things we're hoping to announce in the
next few weeks is a project or a concept
to try to bring Columbia's research and
teaching out into the world and we will
be talking over the next several years
about creating global regional research
centers in multiple areas of the world
so with that let me begin with the
questions if we could start just trying
to get a sense of what this phenomenon
is that we call global
ization and why it's good and we'll get
to the problems in a second Jeff do you
want to start us out sure and what a
great chance to have the discussion so
thanks thanks so much globalization
basically means that we're in each
others face more than ever before the
world is extremely crowded and uniquely
interconnected we have six point six
billion people on the planet population
actually continues to rise very steeply
by about 80 million people every year in
that population increase all of our
production systems have become
internationalized so any company of any
scale has its products produced all over
the world components produced all over
the world trade flows financial flows
now this poses some great opportunities
and some profound of threats the
opportunities are the good things now
traverse the world faster than ever
before especially technology know how
ideas so that parts of the world that
we're stuck in extreme poverty 20 30 40
years ago are dramatically on the rise
in Asia especially China and India are
the exemplars and by virtue of being
almost forty percent of the world's
population the dramatic change of the
world on the other hand bad things also
move faster than ever before so disease
transmission is absolutely global
whether it's ours or AIDS or the fear of
avian flu now terrorism and all of the
threats of rapid interconnection in a
highly unequal world where we don't
really understand each other very well
and the last thing I would say is that
it's all going to become even more
intense because we're on a path of
steeply rising population still in
absolute numbers may be reaching 9
billion people by
century the world economy is expanding
the pressures on the physical
environment and it seems the lack of
understanding and the threats that that
poses are on the rise I would say okay
Joe what is globalization what is
happening well I guess another way of
saying it is just the closer integration
of the country's peoples of the world
partly as a result of changes in
technology lowering transportation costs
communication costs partly as a result
of lowering a lot of the man-made
barriers lowering of tariffs the rules
of the game have changed I think what
Jeff said is absolutely right had some
very positive benefits China India
representing forty percent of the
world's population have been growing at
historically unprecedented rates in the
case of China ten percent for 30 years
India is now getting more attention they
were celebrating New York the 60th
anniversary of Independence been growing
at five six percent for a quarter
century in the last few years at eight
nine percent important to put this in
historical perspective back in 1820
China and India had close to 50 percent
about forty-five percent of global gdp
then a series of exploitation you can
say colonial exploitation a set of rules
of in UK and changes the technology
brought that number way down to under
ten percent and and now that that that
those countries are on the rise and
that's changing really the global
economic and almost surely there for the
global political landscape there are
other aspects that have not been favored
welcome just mention a couple of others
besides the one that just mentioned one
of them is that
global financial markets have become
more integrated and that has meant funds
can go from parks the world where
there's a surplus the parks the world
where there's greater need and that
could promote economic growth but in
fact that's not what's been happening
net last year about half a trillion
dollars went from poor countries to rich
countries and in the last few months
we've seen another manifestation of
problems the global financial markets
the disturbance the turmoil because of
bad financial regulation in the United
States has been exported globally and
that's another aspect of globalization
okay I mean we wanted Susan I want you'd
say that what you think about the
phenomena globalization but I want you
also to begin thinking about what is it
going to look like if it all goes well
out say to 20 30 years so 20 years from
now but Susan complete the the picture
of what is happening and when people
refer to globalization what do you think
we're talking about well globalization
highlights the importance of education
in fact it's an engine driving
educational expansion all over the world
and in the developing world we've yet to
reach the goal of universal primary
education and have great needs to expand
secondary and tertiary education in the
more developed world we're all worrying
about or concerned about whether the
workforce of the 21st century will have
the necessary skills so education is
exceedingly important i think that
globalization also highlights the need
for the promises of technology and puts
a greater premium on developing software
for education that is has universal
applications and globalization enhances
our ability to learn from one another's
educational systems and in our case for
example in the u.s. learning about
greater rigor and focus and the teaching
of mathematics
asian countries so there are many
benefits so this greater and greater
economic integration coupled with the
ability to communicate and interact in
new ways that just were undreamed-of
just a few years ago the sense of
education as a key element we're all
focused on to try to help improve this
we're becoming more interconnected these
are the terms that we use what does it
look like do you think if all things go
reasonably well of course there'll be
some some problems along the way and
maybe there'll be big problems but if
everything keeps going with the forces
now at work what does the world look
like in let's go out 20 25 years 20-30
now I want to get us to think about what
do we need to do in order to prepare for
this world but give us a picture of
these forces continued at work what does
the world look like in in a quarter
century from now Joe do you want to
start on that well let me begin by
saying you know one of the one of the
real problems is that economic
globalization has outpaced the might say
the political globalization the extent
to which we are able to deal with the
problems that closer integration
presents as we become more
interdependent there is more need for
collective cooperative action and we
don't have the democratic institutions
to deal with that so if you started
listing some of the problems as you look
forward for the next two three decades
you realize the profit that the
difficulties we have of you dressing
them one of the problems is the growing
in most countries around the world the
you know citizen makes in the lack of
education that that that it doesn't take
a lot of money to provide universal
primary education and yet that money is
not forthcoming so so there is growing
inequality in most countries the world
we talk about technology and the
Vantage's that it provides and yeah and
it's been a big part of the success of
for instance India but much of Africa
doesn't have access to the technology or
to the educate have a level of education
take advantage of the technology so they
have been falling falling behind so
that's one aspect the growing inequality
a second problem is the financial
turmoil the IMF was created as an
institution to address the problems of
globally integrated financial markets
but it hasn't done it effectively and
didn't anticipate the problems of global
imbalances didn't anticipate the
problems of the subprime workings and
the implications of that and so one
could see a pattern of repeated
financial crisis we had one in 97 just
10 years ago we're having them again
it's clear we have financial problems
and thirdly I think you can't not talk
about the global environmental problems
climate change and while Keota was a
important step in the right direction we
have to remember that it left out three
forced the sources of emissions the
developing countries the United States
deforestation and even within the new
limited areas that addicts something the
targets were not as ambitious as the
world needs from what you say Joe
you say I I can't think about what 20 30
looks like because I see such immense
problems looming ahead and the lack of
institutional ability to address them at
this point that until those are
addressed I just can't anticipate in
other words yeah it's not just
institutional it's buying set I mean
it's a question of we've created this
you might say one economic world yeah
but we aren't thinking that way
particularly the United States and would
you say that would you is it your view
that the institution's we have now
whether it's the UN the World Bank the
IMF all the are not capable as currently
designed to deal with the problems that
are that we're facing and will face was
that your that's right as currently
designed great and then there's a debate
about how they can be performed or
whether they can be reformed okay Susan
out 25 years what does it look like to
you I can envision such a world where
people are learning to let together
collaboratively using technology we're
in the process of starting a project to
create a virtual learning environment
where students in China and in New York
would learn math together in a kind of
second life environment simultaneously
those kinds of things are you know can
only imagine the future a world where
everyone's much more globally aware a
major challenge in the US where
geography and language truly suffer one
can imagine those things but getting
there will require much greater
attention to teacher training throughout
the world much greater attention to the
global skills that people need and a
vast expansion of education in large
parts of the world do you think that the
institutions that
we have are capable of addressing the
educational needs that are required to
sustain this process over the next
couple of decades I actually am weary of
some of the efforts of the multilaterals
I think they often come with a cookie
cutter approach that you know institutes
the same projects in each country and
are less tailored to the individual
countries needs I have more hope for
collaborations bilateral and
multilateral collaborations among
various countries at the governmental
and the university level such as we're
about to with the regional centers Jeff
give us the optimistic view good well
right now there are three billion mobile
phones and there were none virtually ten
years ago and the number is rising a
hundred million subscribers a year in
India hundred million and there are
about 250 million cell phones in Africa
right now and this is a remarkable
demonstration as if we needed one of how
powerful the technologies are that we
have right now and how in a way this
economic system has delivered something
very important and that's another
fundamental technological breakthrough
that can be a vast benefit so what could
be true in I'd say even less than 25
years Lee I've put it to the year 20 25
and that is that right now we have about
a billion people on the planet that's
one sixth of humanity that struggled to
survive every day in what we call
extreme poverty and about 10 million of
their children die every year and this
is something that could disappear from
our planet and from human history if we
play the cards right we don't need to
have extreme poverty in the 21st century
because
the things that are needed to end
extreme poverty are already in our hands
and so it is a matter of recognizing how
powerful our tools are and deciding to
do something about it it's a big if not
an impossible one but that's the kind of
world we could have we live in a world
of incredible danger right now because
poor places are unstable places because
impoverished places produced our for
produce Somalia or produce crises in
Afghanistan and other places and if we
understood these basic dynamics that the
military is not going to solve those
problems but maybe cell phones will we
really have a phenomenal chance right
now so I see 2025 as an opportunity to
live in a world in which every part of
the world feels that they have a chance
for betterment their children are
surviving their children are properly
nourished their children are in school
and that is a choice that we have it's
by no means a sure thing I mean I i
could give you all the the pessimistic
line as well but but that one is not pie
in the sky naive optimism that's just
technologically and economically within
reach if we just grasp grasp for it okay
so let's go to the mindset issue I
assume from things I've heard each of
you say under different circumstances as
well as today that each of you believes
that we whatever that we is but in the
United States Europe around the world
prank we are not thinking about what is
happening right now to us in ways that
will prepare us to address the things
that have to be addressed in order to
succeed with the good side of the things
that are happening
so or not would we need a major change
in the way we look at what's at our own
lives so how would you describe however
not what we're not thinking about what
we're not seeing is that how do we how
do we move ourselves into a new new
mindset Susan if we are not prepared
mentally and emotionally I would put a
large part of the blame on the k-12
system in the United States and perhaps
it's true to some extent in Western
Europe as well in the United States one
quarter of students in 2002 high school
seniors could not only one quarter could
name the ocean between the United States
and Asia seventeen percent knew where
Afghanistan was at a time when we were
engaged in war there Americans don't
take other languages that's fortunately
not true of Europeans who tend to start
at least by age 11 maybe even a third
language by age 13 the global skills
aren't there I understand that America's
decentralization and historic kind of
parochialism get in the way and that the
political climate is changing there's
new competitiveness legislation that
requires States to fit global awareness
skills but we have a long way to go to
develop a globally literate population
yep Joe let me just rate two aspects of
thinking globally one of them is a
question of what would the world be like
if everybody consumes in the kinds of
patterns that Americans consume the cars
that and and we know it's not viable
it's just not feasible and we are
setting the pattern in China India are
all emulating trying to strive for that
kind of consumption pattern and they are
succeeding the numbers I talked to
before is succeeding remarkably well but
that is a
world headed for a collision it just
can't it's not physically viable so the
question is and we know technology can
can can help us address some of these
problems but it's also a question of
patterns of living and so that's one
example that that when you you know the
arithmetic doesn't add up another
example is we talked a lot Americans
talk abut the president talks about
democracy well you know we're all part
of citizens of the world the question is
we make we're interdependent we have to
make decisions collectively what does
that mean to make those democratically
well that means the United States won't
always get its way back to the nature of
democracy the only way you can always
get your way is when you're the dictator
so that mindset that sometimes our views
will not prevail is something which i
think americans have not really fully
absorbed and that the way they have to
get other people to go along with the
way they want is persuasion arguments
not armed forces and I think we've all
seen from Iraq if we had to learn
example in Vietnam that being the
strongest country in the world spending
close to half of the global defense
expenditures in the world doesn't get
you what you want yeah
I think the ultimate survival tool that
we're going to need is empathy and this
is a concept that needs to be cultivated
it's not just about America it's about
Frances about China it's about every
place and it means the ability to see
things out of the eyes of others and it
is going to be our life survival skill
and we don't have it right now we have
very low capacity in almost any part of
the world to calmly stop and have the
courage to see things through the eyes
of a peasant farmer in Africa or through
the eyes of a Palestinian or through the
eyes of Israeli or through the eyes of
an Afghani and I believe that this is by
far the most important single challenge
that we face and it's a matter of
courage because we're too afraid to do
it we're too afraid to get wrapped up in
someone else's interest because we're
too afraid of our own steak and this I
think means that we're so much
scrambling for our place and our
survival that we don't understand that
you have another 6.6 billion people in
the same situation some of them in very
desperate circumstances and we don't
take the time to listen and to think now
maybe 50 years ago or a hundred years
ago or 200 years ago it didn't matter as
much but now it matters absolutely that
we understand this and we do it and it's
the biggest obstacle we face in the
world is fear the second is ignorance
the third is what we really need is
courage we need the courage to to look
at the world from someone
else's point of view if we do that then
if you combine that amount of courage
with the knowledge that we actually have
collectively shared these are solvable
problems but we never get to the
solutions if we're too busy fighting
each other and I think that this is
really what leadership and education and
awareness needs to be about so I put
empathy is our number one survival skill
that we need in the coming years okay I
want to keep driving at this question of
the change in the outlook because partly
because as an educational institution
our primary if but it's certainly a
major goal is to help prepare young
people for the world that they will help
lead so that 25 years out hopefully we
will all be retired and maybe in the
same retirement home and and we'll look
back on this and we'll watch this video
many times together but the people were
teaching now with that they will look
back and they will say I was really well
prepared for this world and I you know
my professors saw it coming and and they
taught me that so we really need to try
to understand this question of what is
different about the outlook we're asking
ourselves and I want to sort of come to
it in an odd way sort of maybe a little
bit of a hypothetical you know you're
advising a leading candidate for
president of the United States right now
let's assume and the candidate says I
just can't make this case I agree with
you we have major problems confronting
the world in the United States over the
next five ten years certainly the next
25 and I want to get the United States
on a course that will be able
to to really do this well but I can't
sell it politically how do I make this
case and and before doing that I want to
ask this question which is a subset and
I think helps to focus it are you
encouraged in this change of mindset
problem by the seemingly very rapid and
significant change about climate change
does that it or is that a fad you see
that as exactly what has to happen
across the board with respect to a
America's role in the world and so or is
this should we take heart in that or
should we not Susan what do you think
climate change but i have found in
working with American policymakers about
internationalizing the k-12 curriculum
which is an area that I've taken up the
banner on that the competitiveness
argument works I understand that we
really want to promote collaboration but
they do resonate to or relatively low
standing and international assessments
the fact that we have wide dispersions
of scores indicating great inequality
within the country around the kind of
skills needed for the 21st century and
one can use their interest in being
competitive to get them to promote the
kind of global understanding that we're
going to need certainly don't want to
stop there we want to move beyond
competition to the kind of collaboration
we need okay so that's a seraph what do
you think about the climate change well
first I every day I say thank God I live
in New York rather than Washington so
because it's a crazy place and in
Washington
and-and-and-and New York is a model of
all of the benefits as well as the
stresses of globalization quite a
different kind of challenge it actually
is a city that exemplifies globalization
at its best which is a thrill so I'm not
sure in the end that the solutions will
come mainly through Washington and
mainly through the political leadership
because the nature of the world is so
different that maybe the solutions are
going to come through university
leadership or come through scientific
leadership or come through leadership of
the Arts and and and others in a
different way it won't just be a global
conference that's going to to solve all
of this what I find absolutely thrilling
really a major change is our campuses
are alive with ideas and with students
interested in the world in a way that
we've not seen for a long time and so
you go to any campus hours without
question but any campus around the u.s.
right now students want to get involved
in the world they want to get involved
in the challenges of poverty and the
challenges of the environment and
globalization they want their study your
abroad they want to do summer
internships they want to be out there
because they know that's the world that
they're going to be in so my view is I
don't know what these political
consultants tell the politicians but i
think they tell them junk in general
because what i hear coming out of the
politicians mouths is so bad and
unconvincing that it makes you cringe
we're still feeding fear we're still
feeding the US versus them even if you
know competitiveness is the mode of
argument a better mode of argument is we
should be improving ourselves and bed
education and so forth not we have to do
it because otherwise we're going to lose
in competition to the Chinese or to
whatever so we're still stuck in this
lack of empathy and an us-versus-them
mindset but it's not the only way to go
and what we see on the campuses i
believe is something that can be tapped
in terms of real leadership for really
the kinds of problem solving in the
global view point that we need and I
haven't seen italy for from the 1980s
and the 1990s we didn't have that in a
way September 11 change things it as
screwed up as our response was if you'll
excuse me it opened the eyes of people
to the world both to the dangers the
possibilities the need to be involved
and I think that this is again something
that can go in wildly divergent
directions but there is the possibility
to harness this for a lot of true global
leadership problem solving and
cooperation and that's what we have to
pull right now I don't know if our
presidents are going to do that but our
society can do that ok can I go back to
the example you gave of climate change I
was at the Clinton Global Initiative
earlier this week and you could feel
their a really strong almost unanimity
that manat that this was a
representative of the whole country but
a strong sayings that something had to
be done about climate change I think
what has changed the climate about
climate change are some of the very
salient facts that have come home you
know the rapid melting of the of the
polar ice cap the the reality of what
were theoretical calculations a hundred
years ago and and
forecast maybe 10 years ago are visible
today I think to switch to the issue of
of some of the aspects of globalization
one of the problems was that 15 years
ago there was a lot of rhetoric theory
about globalization that was just wrong
people were saying everybody's going to
be better off and as long as people
believe that globalization was going to
make everybody better off you didn't
have to deal with the problem that many
people were being made worse off so that
the reality hadn't intrude intruded into
the political discourse and the
political discourse was a very
ideological discourse what has happened
and I think this is positive is the
reality that some people are being made
worse off as a result of globalization
has really changed the nature of the
debate this is where I think
universities have an important role the
politicians are basically in marketing
they have some idea given to them by
somebody else typically and they're
selling it they don't understand the the
overall theory economics politics of
whether of what going on I think the
universities are the place where
dispassionate analysis of what is really
going on ought to be occurring and where
proposals to deal with the adverse
effects can come up in a dispassionate
way and and that's where you know when
when as academics were called upon to
give advice my own view is that we are
to to to focus on those analytic issues
to try to explain no here are the here
are the adverse effects and here are
some of the ways you can do it without
some concomitant negative adverse
ancillary effects Susan
oh I agree I do feel that climate change
has certainly made some difference in
the emerging k-12 curriculum you can see
it I think a major problem that we have
and talking about primary secondary
education is that these kinds of global
issues are often relegated to social
studies or you know your global studies
class and don't permeate reading which
is a has such a great emphasis right now
all countries are measuring their
reading skills they don't permeate the
books that are used in primary education
more broadly so there are many
challenges but I do see some signs of
change one of the things I think we can
do I wonder if we can do pioneer some of
them also already doing it is getting
kids in classrooms in the u.s. to be
directly interactive with kids elsewhere
you need your little camera on top of a
computer and you have classrooms all
over the world then connected together
and the opportunity for kids not just to
read in a book what it's like in a
village in Africa or in Shanghai or
whatever but actually to be experiencing
that directly is not some technological
fantasy but absolutely immediately
apparent right now thank you add a
project which they were trying to do yes
I see that so it seems to me that again
we just have to be fostering ways to
make this happen demonstrating models
and and with others and helping to bring
that about and that brings to life these
issues for for kids at the right time
when they can really get engaged I
totally agree would love to collaborate
and want to emphasize your use of the
word we I think that we as a university
community and joining with others can do
a lot without waiting for the
policymakers to act for example the goal
of universal primary
education in the developing world and
the expansion of secondary education is
stymied by a huge teacher shortages you
know absolute shortages we're in some
sub-saharan countries the ratio is 70
primary students to one teacher but even
when the bodies are there ill prepared
teachers teachers who were accent much
of the time there's much that we can do
collaboratively with universities and
others on the ground in these countries
to make those situations better 68
months ago all the experts except for a
few and maybe they were just lucky in
their guesses said that we were going to
have a break of the bubble in the
housing market and we were going to have
a problem with mortgages that had been
given to people who were too high risk
and there was a problem with the way in
which these had been securitized and
this was out there and people didn't
know the level of risk that they had
taken even big institutions this was all
discussed as a looming problem very few
people and again maybe they were just
lucky but very few people said that's
going to bring the world financial
system to the brink of collapse and it
did bring it to the brink of collapse a
near panic almost ensued and it appears
as if we walk back from the brink
although everybody is on pins and
needles thinking that we didn't get that
one right what's out there that but it's
also a dove metaphor perhaps of how the
world works that we're not prepared to
fully absorb as we think about so
there's a very positive feeling still
about the global interconnected
in the rise of China and India even
Africa is improving and and all of this
looks basically pretty good how do you
think about that undercurrent of things
we just don't see that might lead to
catastrophe Jeff well I think that
there's no doubt a lot of serious
trouble that we haven't recognized yet
and we have narrowly dodged the bullet
in several cases let me just name a
couple quickly the discovery that
humankind was destroying the
stratospheric ozone was an absolutely
accidental discovery in a series of
papers between 1971 and 1975 that ended
up producing three Nobel Prizes but
nobody was looking for it exactly it
wasn't a great issue that what are we
doing we better find out it was an
accident of three wonderful scientists
Rowland Molina and crutzen who
discovered this and then it got verified
and fortunately we were able to find a
technological fix sours came out of
nowhere it nearly brought the Chinese
economy to a halt and then it yet my
quarantine ian was able actually to get
under control but there have been a lot
of the so-called zou anodic diseases
where an animal disease is transferred
to the human population and because of
globalization somebody takes a plane
from from Hong Kong to Toronto and all
of a sudden you have a worldwide
epidemic so the first thing is there are
lots of problems under the surface that
we because of the way we're pressing so
hard on global physical limits right now
that we need to understand and we need
to be investing heavily in and of course
this is a fundamental role of
universities all those discoveries were
university discoveries and we better be
making
such investments because we know those
things are happening second basic point
is that we've got to avoid the panic
situations that is the tipping points or
the so-called abrupt or nonlinear
changes were you let things drift so
long that boom you get an explosion and
the general lesson of life is that if
you stay in a range of moderation and
don't press things to the limit you can
avoid those kinds of collapses but if
you really drive things to the end and
say well you know it doesn't really
matter we can keep going keep going keep
going then you find out oh I forgot
about that the whole system collapses
much more than we thought and we're
pressing on that geopolitically
economically environmentally on many
fronts where we can predict not exactly
what's going to happen or when but that
there's a high risk of something
abruptly going wrong go yeah global
warming illustrates these very strong
nonlinearities that are coming to play
and and it's one of the reasons why we
underestimated the pace with which the
Arctic Ocean is is melting and there are
a lot of other nonlinearities the point
that Jeff makes is absolutely right it's
a very dangerous experiment nobody in
their right mind would have said ass
looks let's do an experiment let's
double triple the amount of greenhouse
gases in the atmosphere and see what
happens you know you'd be out of your
mind unless you have some other plan to
go too but we'll just do it just on
earth we won't do it elsewhere alright
so that's the kind of example where
you're really pressing on the limits of
our knowledge you're not sure and yet
we're going ahead now in the going back
to the the more mundane issue of these
toxic new instruments financial
instruments subprime mortgages that's
the kind of area where at
research I think actually had
highlighted a lot of the problems and
there is a disparity here between the
incentives of those in the market who
are inevitably going to be enthusiastic
about new products particularly if they
can sell them and make money and a more
dispassionate analysis of what the
economic consequences so let me give you
an example in the old world bank's made
loans mortgages if the mortgage turned
out bad the bank paid the consequences
if the borrower had problems the the
bank could negotiate with the borrower
and said you know we understand you're
having a temporary problem will extend
will extend your terms will will will
avoid foreclosure because everybody
loses under under a foreclosure what we
did with securitization which have one
big advantage a diversified risk
globally we persuaded Australian banks
Paris banks in Paris to buy these toxic
instruments and to take our problems off
of our shores it was a brilliant move
but it created what we call in the
economics Information Agency problems
the people originating the mortgages got
their money upfront their incentive at
that point was to get others to take
them off their hands not to give
accurate information but to dump them as
fast as they could and they did now when
the problem arises it's not the original
bank but somebody else in Australia or
Paris or who bears the consequence but
Glenn when it when it comes time to
renegotiate you can't renegotiate the
this this mortgage is held by thousands
of people in different pieces the
contracts are designed to make it
virtual
possible renegotiate and the result of
this is that they're estimating about
1.7 million Americans will lose their
home there'll be foreclosures of
unprecedent magnitudes as a result so
that's an example it was clear about
what these trade-offs were clear that
there were problems but there are a lot
of people who had an incentive to push
these particular instruments and and and
the market in accents didn't work in the
way it should have before going to Susan
I want to follow up on that Joe with you
because you've made the point today
you've made it repeatedly and with great
power and success to put it in your own
words that our social political
institutions are not matched to our
economic practices and so on and this is
a this is an example of that or how far
behind our way and I know there's a long
question we've got to go to audience you
know one possibility is we're just so
far behind on our political institutions
that we're going to have a very big
problem through the financial
integration because precisely the
subprime that you just described is
going to replicate itself in other
examples and we've got it it's not an
optimistic outlook or do you think that
actually the social institutions and
regulatory institutions could catch up
pretty quickly if there were just a
change in outlook and people said look
we got a problem we've got to fix this
and build some institutions and so on
well I guess I'm halfway between those
two views on the one hand I think the
country has gone through what I think is
a very bad episode and it's been going
on in some ways for for a while we're
there is a particular school of thought
that has been pushing the idea that you
don't need government governments to
prob
that a particular ideology that says all
the government is designed to do is to
give transfers to companies like
Halliburton and and you know make the
rich richer that there's a particular
perspective on the role of government I
think there is a reaction against that
and it's a view that is a particular
peculiarly I think view in a limited
number of places so I think there will
be a reaction on that and I think our
overall understanding of the limitations
of that perspective are are actually
sucks that we could catch up relatively
quickly okay that's the other part of
the story is markets are very clever no
matter what regulations are there are
people who will be figuring out how to
get around them and there's a constant
battle of trying to figure out you know
new technologies that allow us to get
around to create new problems and new
technologies that allow us to solve the
new problems that the new technologies
create that's part of the excitement of
you know of being at in a modern world
excitement at the University that
there's always going to be that kind of
chewing of growing okay Susan you will
well for me the most serious threat is
that we in the US will continue exactly
the way we are unaware of other
countries graduating only eighteen
percent of any ninth grade class from
college that's how the completion rates
have deteriorated and not worrying about
huge inequities but I guess there's also
the converse threat of mindless
borrowing from other countries in the
name of globalization like my favorite
or most egregious example is Singapore
Math which is sweeping suburban
districts in the United States without
any evidence about its suitability or
its
activeness interesting okay let's go to
these questions let's just take let's
try to go through them just one person
perhaps answer the question is we've
talked a lot about today about roles for
politicians and universities in finding
solutions what can the private sector
due to find solutions Jeff I was also
going to respond to this earlier
question about what institutions we need
and this is helpful how do you make an
international very diverse international
interconnected world solve problems when
we don't have and we don't want a world
government and when governments don't
have the answers because a lot of the
answers are outside of the political
setting so to me this is really a big
and basic question how do you solve
complex global problems and I just
wanted to give one example because I
think that there is an interesting way
to do this that is a little bit
different from a normal way of problem
solving and it involves the question of
extreme poverty and the goals that we've
set the so-called Millennium Development
Goals and something that I have the
chance to work on it with the United
Nations now you can't solve the
millennium development goals without
government's taking action without
universities studying problems without
new technologies and without the private
sector making commitments for the poor
and so you need a whole interconnected
ensemble there's no conductor but there
is a global Orchestra and the question
is can you get any sound out of it that
is an awful and it seems to me it seems
to me that the answer starts in a little
bit of an odd way which is the world's
actually agreed on a number of goals it
agreed specifically on targets for
reducing child mortality
maternal mortality it's already agreed
to stabilize greenhouse gas emissions in
something called the UN framework
convention on climate change it's agreed
to slow the loss of biodiversity and
something called the convention on
biological diversity and so on my view
is that the right starting point for
this diverse world is to take seriously
the things we have agreed to as things
that we've actually agreed to now it's a
little bit of a bootstrap operation but
so is law and so is government you have
to believe that it's important when you
make agreements to actually honor those
agreements and then work towards the
goals that you've set and so my way of
thinking is not to look for a global
government or a global political
solution alone but rather to keep our
focus on shared global commitments that
are explicitly stated and then we're the
private sector the public sector can all
add their pieces to the solution so when
you ask what's the role of the private
sector finally if you're thinking about
the issue of extreme poverty it may be
to donate your medicines for deworming
children or to make sure that people
with AIDS have the access to
antiretroviral medicines when large
companies do that often in partnership
with the public sector you can get
remarkable results but without the gold
that we ought to do that and taking
seriously the goal that we ought to do
that we we won't get anywhere no one
will know how to fit their part into a
larger setting so let me put it a
different way we need to make
international law something more real
than it is because these are
international legal agreements to an
important extent rather than viewing
international law as a joke or a
stepchild or a special case we actually
have to understand that even without a
global government we can still have an
international legal framework in which
we act
and in which private and public sectors
can then add their pieces to solutions
all of this is to say we don't have
either substantively or in mind set the
kinds of institutions to solve this but
we also shouldn't pretend that somehow
we're going to create a neat single
global package to do it it's a messy
world and we have to understand how to
solve problems in a very messy and
complicated world okay Joe I'd like you
to try to answer this in around 30
seconds or less what is the relevance of
the World Bank today I'm timing you okay
well the problem of global poverty of
poverty in developing countries is a
very real problem and the World Bank is
one of the most important international
institutions which is focused on that
issue it goes back to the question we
need these international institutions
they aren't fully addressing issues as
effectively as they could or as they
should but the need for the World Bank
to to work on this issue is this very
it's very very clear it was a little
over 30 seconds but now we're to add for
me me not bad so it continues to have a
very important role that's know them and
how much is of the year twenty billion
or so I mean the fact is that it's a a
small amount of money relative both to
what is spent and what really ought to
be spent and it has always have at least
in recent years have the vision that the
most effective way a way to be the most
effective is demonstration to show that
you can do certain things
that can be imitated to be wrecking ball
the some of the problems in the past and
even today have been that it is tried to
push particular solutions on country
music's impose conditionalities
undermine democracy and its own
governance obviously is very flawed I
think when you mention the amounts it's
really important always and this is one
of the hard things to keep amounts in
relative perspective so the world bank
may spend about ten billion dollars a
year of its concessional financing that
is the low interest money but consider
that the Pentagon spends 1.1 million
dollars a minute and it's Ben's 1.7
billion dollars a day and it's Ben's
there for about six hundred twenty
billion dollars a year so we're in a
complete dis proportion between
different needs and that's a very
serious problem of arithmetic political
arithmetic right now I just can I get
just just to highlight this the Pentagon
request for the war in Iraq for two
thousand eight is sixteen billion
dollars a month so that's a number to
put in context of what the World Bank is
spending on the whole world Susan a
question is is the United States role as
a moral leader over
these are terrible questions I'm not
sure when we were moral leaders I mean
when just to take the my own
institutions history teachers college
was a very international institution
from very early on and in the early 20th
century we were known throughout the
world for technical assistance in
education but our goal was a missionary
one we knew best we were spreading our
version of democracy throughout the
world I think the challenge for us in
education today is to understand we have
as much to learn as we have to give and
that all our associations you know from
training teachers to doing research
collaboratively have to be in that
spirit do you think today looking at the
u.s. educational system that there is a
sense of importance of educating young
people to a moral leadership role in the
world oh very mixed I you know you see
some leadership in the Congress around
that and 26 states have task forces to
look at global awareness in the
curriculum there are certainly social
studies teachers who cared about this
but beyond those constituencies I think
you know the focus in the united states
since No Child Left Behind is reading
and math scores at grades three through
eight and essentially our system has
narrowed its energy on that the
troubling or the problematic concept is
is leadership as opposed to moral
responsibility because the US is five
percent of the world's population and we
need actually moral responsibility from
all parts of the world it's not that one
country is the leader and others are
somehow followers and is it is
shared moral responsibility that's the
most important thing right now and at
times the US with others have displayed
this in the most incredible and glorious
ways and a time so the United States but
many other countries have failed in the
most miserable ways and the real change
for the future is less about leadership
and more about global shared commitments
and shared responsibilities this is a
world of problems and it's going to
require a world effort of solutions and
that's a shared concept I think rather
than a leadership concept per se yeah
and can I just look up on something like
Jeff said earlier and the notion of
empathy which i think is is an important
concept here you have to understand
others to have that kind of empathy and
and that's a sense in which I think we
haven't really done as much as we should
have having empathy for the audience is
also important and I really want to say
how grateful we are for the questions
how grateful to the panelists we've been
really privileged to to listen to all of
you think about these incredibly
important subjects of course they're
integral to what we're thinking about
for Columbia and we ask that you pay
close attention to how we're doing in